after 20 years it was a hostile
departure for the united states from its
kabul embassy
as the taliban reached the city limits
helicopters ferried staff to kabul
international airport
those who remained burned sensitive
documents while blackhawks and apache
helicopters circled the capital
monitoring for taliban fighters on the
ground
as they released heat flares over the
green zone president ashraf ghani was
recording what would be his final
statement he and his core team fled the
country shortly after
there is a clear need that the national
directorate of security alongside the
police and the afghan army take
responsibility for the security of all
citizens i have asked the defense
minister and the interior minister to
convey that message anyone who's
disturbing the law and order or things
of looting should be confronted with
full force
before ghani left kabul the afghan
government had been negotiating with the
taliban for a political settlement but
its leverage had weakened with every
loss on the battlefield
in just nine days the taliban took
control of every major city except kabul
by sunday morning its fighters
surrounded the capital holding districts
inside kabul province so it is a popular
uprising
and all the proper provinces are with us
so they should
understand and know the ground realities
and
surrender to submit themselves to the
will of the people there will be a
government which
will be acceptable
to all afghans as the taliban presence
built around the outskirts of kabul the
armed groups military commission sent
this message to its fighters
congratulations to you all but no one
should enter kabul you do not have
permission to enter if someone enters
you cannot plead ignorance
yet by sunset the taliban flag was
raised inside kabul city taliban
fighters were seen driving around on
motorbikes in pickup trucks and humvees
greeting the people
afghanistan's interior ministry carried
on undeterred stating it remains in
charge of the city's security
the security of the city is guaranteed
and it is not going to be attacked the
agreement is that there is going to be a
peaceful transfer of power to a
transitional government do not be
influenced by any propaganda kabul is
safe rest assured there will not be any
problem in kabul
but after the taliban's rapid march
across afghanistan that was not a chance
the u.s or it would seem president ghani
was willing to take
charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul